here we go again Sony have revealed the
six No the eight free games we'll be
receiving as part of PS plus for the
month of August 2018 and oh my goodness
it's a damn good month as always these
games will be available from around
midday on the first Tuesday of the month
this time around that's the seventh of
August let's start with the offerings on
ps4 and first up is the exceptional
Mafia 3 it's an open-world crime fest
set back in the 1960s in a reimagining
of new orleans known as new bordeaux
first released in October 2016 mafia 3
follows Lincoln Clay as he returns from
the Vietnam War the story and acting are
fantastic packed with political tension
and top-notch action seems all
complemented by great visuals and
impressive sound design mechanically
though this isn't up to the same
standards as say GTA 5 and feels
repetitive if you don't commit to the
narrative the reviews reflected this
feeling with scores ranging from as low
as two out of five to seven out of ten
from your friends over at IGN you're
gonna have to download this one and see
which of the review scores you agree
with next up we have a slice of survival
horror to get your teeth into this is
dead by daylight but it's not the
standard version it's the special
edition complete with additional maps
killers and survivors if you're new to
asymmetric multiplayer here's a
breakdown one player begins the game as
the killer most of which are based on
movie murderers like Michael Myers they
are tasked with eliminating everyone in
the game all those other people must
survive and attempt to escape by using
the right tools and working together
there's a lot of blood in this one so
it's not for the squeamish ps+ gives us
two additional games this month with the
first being the play link titled
knowledge is power
your task is to get your mate around and
use your phones
answering questions and dragging
yourself to victory that's not the end
though there's also a psvr title here
too here they lie described as a dark
psychological horror I'm not sure how I
feel about this one but I'm tempted to
make a follow-up let's play video here
they light asks you with uncovering a
mystery buried in your nightmares come
on whose man are woman enough to try
this one over on the ps3 is serious Sam
BFP it's a throwback to the golden
generation of first-person shooters it's
a balls-to-the-wall rampage through so
many different types of weapons you'll
definitely get used to the sight of
blood with Serious Sam released almost
seven years ago it hasn't aged
fantastically well but it's a great nod
to the 90s next on the ps3 is bound by
flame a fantasy themed action RPG from
back in 2014
your character is possessed by a demon
sounds lovely doesn't it all the typical
RPG elements are here designing your own
characters crafting weapons and
upgrading passive and active abilities
game informer love this one and gave it
8 out of 10 over on the Vita is Space
Hulk if you're a fan of Warhammer 40k
you'll probably already know about Space
Hulk but if not this is a turn-based
strategy game officially licensed by
Games Workshop it takes its rules from
the classic board game with added
cinematics to spice up the narrative
definitely one for the enthusiasts its
average 6 point 5 out of 10 in reviews
and finally draw slasher this one is
telefon draw slasher uses the
touchscreen to both move your character
and attack using gestures it doesn't
take itself seriously and allows you to
cut monkeys in half think of it like a
gruesome fruit ninja definitely worth
the download so there we have it eight
games to get your teeth into on top of
this are the PlayStation exclusive skin
and back bling that are still available
in fortnight battle royale and a few
goodies for fallout shelter and h1z1 -
so what's the month's theme blood and
violence I can't wait to try dead by
daylight and maybe the psvr horror title
if I can pluck up the courage what are
you grabbing I'd love to know your
thoughts throw them down in the comments
below
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]